sure and I guess part of this is just
like you're trying to calculate you know
how quickly can you get the crews back
out and get the rigs back up and running
there's also this calculation of like
they can say the cities are open or the
states are open but actually how long
does it take for consumers to start you
know demanding or consuming right yeah
and we can measure a real time demand so
we were able to measure a real time
electricity demand real time you know we
can see power burns every day every
minute so we're tracking the demand
pretty well right it's hard to forecast
like it kept you kind of get worse but
we're tracking it pretty well and have a
reasonable idea of what the bottom is
right New York City's completely shut
down but it's the power demand is down
11% so we kind of know right so the main
thing right now is like okay when does
this faucet become a problem right when
does the supply issue become a problem
right now it's not a problem not a
problem at all
matter of fact is the exact opposite we
might we have too much gas but that
switch is gonna flip and what it flips
given the current circumstances if we
stay on this path it could be violent to
the upside yeah and so what it sounds
like you're really kind of highlighting
right now you've got a surplus from a
supply side demand has gone down a
little bit but because you realize
you've got the surplus and demands down
people are actually shutting down
production supply incoming supplies
almost slowing and so when that demand
comes flying back there could be a
moment in time where people are caught
without enough supply and that's where
the problem would come in yeah like
people are just starting cutting the
production and associated production so
you know these guys you know also the
costs the break-even cost and well has
changed right if you look at the
interest cost you know drilling is a
leveraged business right and you know
there's been studies done in the
Marcellus like what are the break evens
at different interest rates but if you
look at like the cost of capital for the
drillers they basically have doubled on
average so I don't know if the price
break even is you know
what you want the supply you want and so
that that's another thing I'm looking at
but generally right now
you know I say there's things like
there's tweezer trades where you have to
be really accurate and really nuanced
and know every single little detail and
there's sledgehammer trays
huge macro thing is happening you don't
need all the details you have enough
room for our you just pile it right and
I think the further we get in time this
goes from tweezers to sledgehammer